o escutava a todos eo processo não estar
aqui e falar com vocês em razão de eu
estar aqui como diz a marta é porque eu
tenho um escritório como melhor vista do
planeta que exista
eu trabalho aqui é o grande do sul que
todos nós conhecemos que é o céu nem
preso às vezes sem nuvens brancas às
vezes é cor laranja às vezes é trabalhar
às vezes é cor rosa e vou partilhar um
carinho da minha experiência como é que
eu cheguei
é uma situação de concretizar um sonho
de ser piloto de caças piloto quer
passar mais algum de vocês aqui gostaria
de ser piloto de aviões
pois bem eu tenho mas não virá para vos
dar a vocês todos podem ser tudo aquilo
que vocês quiserem
é importante que nunca desistam do sonho
que tem sempre e nunca desistem
descontentaram e então essa minha
aventura começou com dez anos eu entrei
para o ex-militar sonda que os críticos
estatal e é e nessa altura eu tinha os
mesmos sonhos e os mesmos gostos que
vocês têm hoje eu gostava de jogar à
bola que estava a fazer desporto
se houvesse playstation na altura de
certeza absoluta que eu iria adorar
jogar pois taxa mas não havia e foi
aquilo com as militar é que eu tive
minha primeiro é a minha primeira
experiência o meu primeiro contacto com
os aviões numa actividade que nós
fazemos que era era o morumbi jun é o
humanismo ea construção de aviões desde
as asas da fuselagem pois metros um
motor pequenino e depois de uma pista de
aeromodelismo daquelas que na volta e
tentamos pilotar os aviões eu confesso
que não tinha muita gente pra que os
primeiros 56 que construir destruídos
assim que aos claro porque não tinha
muita gente pra aquilo mas o fascínio
por avião estava lá e eu contei os 14
anos se ele está ou quer fazer e eu
quero ser piloto de aviões
e talvez pelo meu pai que eu acabei
problema é cdu com 8 anos ter sido a
força aérea embora não fosse piloto eu
tive sempre me intrigava os aviões então
treinamos eu não quero ser um piloto
dias com a qual quer eu quer ser um
piloto casa
quero voar os melhores aviões que
existem e então com 19 anos
a decisão estava tomada e e teve quer
ser piloto da força aérea que quer ser
oficial da força aérea
e assim foi concorri e entrar à força
aérea
e aqui e quando eu entro com a força
aérea que é minha vida muda radicalmente
porque há por que deixar de ser dono do
meu tempo livre eu e vocês imaginem o
que é ter que estar sempre disponível 24
horas por dia todos os dias do ano
não interessa se é natal se a fim de ano
se a festa de anos da mãe do pai dos
amigos
eu provei muitas porque tinha que estar
disponível mas valeu a pena
valeu a pena e é porque fui crescendo e
fui acreditando que era possível e
chegar a atingir este meu sonho
durante a minha estadia é na academia da
força aérea e nós éramos fomos eu e os
meus colegas fomos sempre sendo sujeito
a várias provas muito difíceis muito
duras nomeadamente imaginem uma simular
e que tem que sobreviver no meio do
deserto e sem água sem alimentos ou
sobreviver no meio do mar e em todas
estas provas que fui passando e volta e
meia vinha irá existir mas como entre
ajudem para nós era tão forte que nós
próprios nos tornamos mais fortes e
conseguimos ir ultrapassando os nossos
jogos diversos problemas e obstáculos
que se iam aparecendo na frente é que
nessa altura também que eu tenho a mania
que era um bebê maluco então vou fazer
um desporto radical e que proclame qual
foi esse era o desporto com que mais
medo eu decidi fazer que era o livro eu
sou e no capacete e queria fazer isso
porque e eu tenha medo e alturas
gente e então eu quis enfrentar o meu
medo é a mensagem que quero passar aqui
também é pra você se enfrentarem os
nossos medos e vão descobrir quando nos
enfrentam e aos vamos aparecer bem isto
é esta parte daquela livros como querem
que eu fiz mais de 200 shout e teve nem
todos
nem todos os shout mas cada vez que tive
mesmo eu enfrentei o mesmo e conseguir
suprir ao e nos autos que ir outra vez e
nos salta seguir outra vez passava o els
45 anos com o meu sonho nosso que irá e
eu tornei piloto de caça piloto combate
primeiro vou a estes aviões que estão a
ver que o acerto é um avião com a nossa
força aérea não tem já não tem já muito
antigo e seguramente vou aí eo ainda
atualmente o melhor avião no mundo
fui piloto east side e o que é que você
quer dizer com isto e isto foi um sonho
tornado realidade
eu acreditei sempre que conseguir
esforçarem exigiu muito estudo muito
trabalho muito sacrifício e mexe eu
consegui achar e pega aí uma palavra do
meu dicionário eu tinha um dicionário
português hoje em dia vai usar a
internet e descobrir as palavras o
significado na altura num novo via
internet da forma que conhecemos hoje
então eu peguei uma palavra que é a
palavra desistir desistir não é opção
nós não devemos desistir das coisas
devemos tentar tentar sempre e nunca
desistir como piloto militar é é a
missão que eu tinha e os outros pilotos
falavam comigo era defender os céus
portugal o nosso espaço aéreo embora
possa parecer que seja uma missão de
combate não era uma missão de paz
manutenção página para que para que os
povos possam viver em harmonia uns com
os outros países possam viver em
harmonia uns com os outros e termos um
planeta mais seguro para todos vivermos
em uma dura no irã hoje e norma como
podem imaginar essa imagem promover
imaginem vocês quando vão com os vossos
pais na auto-estrada e vão a 100 km por
hora ou 120 km por hora que é bastante
pressa e eu aqui não é 6 nesta imagem do
perto de dois mil quilômetros por hora
duas vezes a velocidade do som é melhor
ser melhor e maior sensação de
adrenalina que vocês podem imaginar ter
ao longo dos anos enquanto piloto
combate
nós treinávamos sempre como combatemos e
eu larguei bombas de treino e mísseis
quase todos os dias começa a questão
aqui é ver fizemos missões de combate é
simulados aéreos uns com os outros quase
todos os dias e em todos os dias eu vou
dizer uma coisa e nós tínhamos sempre
uma presença muito forte dentro do
cockpit comigo eu estava sozinho com a
vítima estava há sempre uma presença que
é o medo de falhar
nós não podemos falhar porque quando
falhamos um piloto combate quando falha
o mais provável que aconteça é um
acidente e nós não queremos que isso
aconteça que isso aconteça
fui mexendo e continua a ensinar ainda
os tonys um senador e com 32 anos seria
não mas eu agora o meu sonho como estava
mesmo mesmo mesmo fazer era viajar
conhecer o mundo conhecer povos
diferentes e aconteceria e concorrerá
para atacar quando os pilotos na etapa
quando tap e entrei na tap e vai este
provisões que ainda vou hoje que vocês
tenham que ver e e passar de uma
situação que era achava achava que era o
maior da minha rua era um top gun para
voltar que ter é terá que estudar eu
tinha vocês lá e ficava furioso com os
professores porque nós tínhamos testes
todos os meses todas as semanas aquilo
era uma chatice master test fazer exames
é uma coisa boa porque nós tornamos de
melhor
eu ainda hoje todos os anos seis em seis
meses organizamos para poder continuar
sem piloto e vou ter exames
é é acabar a minha carreira portanto
quando pense nisso quando tiverem teste
para fazer que é uma chatice temos que
dar é uma coisa boa e isso é uma coisa
boa porque nós tornamos melhores mais
eficiente e conseguiu chegar mais longe
mais ao ar em torno de mais forte e como
o piloto da tap hoje em dia missão já
não é defender o chelsea portugal mas
sim defender os passageiros e o céu o
que eu quero dizer com isso quando vocês
forem meus passageiros quando eu for o
nosso comandante
podem ter a certeza que eu vou dar o meu
melhor para os defender para vocês terem
um vôo mais surtos todos vou tentar
fazer a melhor arbitragem todas não sei
se vou conseguir mas pronto
vamos ver defender o chelsea portugal o
céu portugal como como avanço da
tecnologia os aviões hoje em dia são
cada vez melhor
ele foi o melhor são menos poluentes
mais rápido e nem eu próprio enquanto
piloto dentro coop titânio procedimentos
para diminuir a poluição
para tornar o o céu o melhor é mais
limpa e mais renovável e temos um
planeta para todos que é nós todos mais
saudável para respirarmos é o que eu
faço hoje eu sou piloto
sou pai tenho amigos com quem mudou de
vez em quando faço de porto joga
voleibol em patins em linha fascinou
bordo de fotografias e tem pouco tempo
livre e no meu tempo livre eu tento
ajudar o próximo time e volta
o que eu quero dizer com isto nós
devemos ajudar as pessoas estão à nossa
volta seja os nossos irmãos nossos pais
dos nossos prêmios os nossos amigos
nossos que incite inclusivamente os que
nós não conhecemos lado nenhum porque se
nós fizermos isso e não vamos conseguir
mudar o mundo todo mas conseguimos mudar
este muito pequenino que está à nossa
volta e escrevam nós destas pessoas que
nos ajudaram disse ajudar mas alguém vai
ser melhor e vamos tornar o mundo melhor
vamos tornar o planeta melhor um melhor
lugar para se viver
para terminar porque eu quero vos dizer
sony sempre
eu sei que queria ser piloto da seta
criando a fazer loopings e conseguir eu
não sou melhor que você achou exatamente
igual a vocês eu sim aí que queria ser
piloto de f do site e andar de cabeça
pra baixo num avião nunca saber se
conseguir eu não sou melhor que eu seja
eu sou exatamente igual
nunca desistam antes tentar a primeira
vez em quando tentarem se falharem se
caírem não faz mal
levantem outra vez e tentar outra vez e
só parei falhar e voltarei aqui não faz
mal volta em salvador e tente outra vez
e outra e outra e outra e de ver se for
necessário porque vocês vão conseguir
quanto mais difícil é o objetivo mas o
melhor é a sensação quando conseguirmos
atingir e também quando trabalhamos em
grupo começa imagem tom que ver que eu
estou no meio destes aviões tornamos
mais fortes a união de nós todos faz a
força conseguimos chegar mais longe mas
a wine sony e sempre nunca deixem de
sonhar de querer de acreditar e depois
deste processo que tem que fazer
acontecer
nunca deixem que ninguém vos diga que
não conseguem emitir vocês conseguem
tudo
eita cabo como com sai
vocês podem ser tudo que vocês quiserem
obrigado